[موسيقى]
من الغياب والتخلي الى الهويه والجذور
فالاختلاف والمصير مفاهيم معقده اجتمعت في
قصص انسانيه ابطالها اطفال
بالتبني التبني كلمه حرمت في الاسلام خوفا
من اختلاط الانساب كما فسروا استبدلوها
بالكفاله فحرمت اطفالا من حقهم في النسب
والميراث وبين من يتحايل على القوانين من
اجل ان يتبنى ومن يتاجر بماسي ايتام
وعائلات لا تنجب يضيع حق ملايين الاطفال
في الرعايه والحب والامان حق من المفترض
ان يكون مقدسا فهل يشرع التبني في فلك
الممنوع بدات القصه عام
2018 يوم عثرت امال على طفل عمره بضعه
ايام داخل كنيسه العذراء ام النور شمال
القاهره احتضنته مع زوجها فصار ابنا لهما
بعد ان حرمتهما الحياه من انجاب طفل
بيولوجي اسمياه شنوده وربه في كن فهما
اربع سنوات الى ان اتى اليوم المشؤوم خلاف
على الميراث بين وال شنوده واخته جعلها
تطعن في نسب الطفل اخذ شنوده من حطن
والديه وتم وضعه في دار ايتام تابع للدوله
واصدرت السلطات المعنيه شهاده ميلاد جديده
له باسم جديد ودين جديد من شنو القبطي الى
يوسف
المسلم ما دفع اسرته لرفع دعوه قضائيه
وخوض معركه قانونيه لاستعاده حق كفالته
وبعد سته اشهر من المداولات بين المحكمه
الاداريه ومحامي الاسره قضت محكمه القضاء
الاداري في مصر بعدم اختصاصها بالنظر في
القضيه ليكتمل فيلم الرعب الذي يعيشه
الابوان ثم اتى موقف الازهر حاسما الجدل
الديني هذه المساله ذهب فيها العلماء الى
اراء متعدده والذي يميل اليه الازهر من
بين هذه الاراء هو ما ذهب اليه فريق من
الساده الحنفيه وهو ان الطفل المجهول
النسب اذا وجد في كنيسه وكان الواجد غير
مسلم فهو على دين من وجده عاد شنوده الى
امه وابيه بالتمني ابني في حضني اخيرا
وسوف اقدم له حياتي كلها وسوف اعوضه عما
تعرض من حرمان خلال عام داخل الدار عائله
شنوده تعهدت بحسن رعايته والمحافظه عليه
وعدم تعريضه للخطر وهي تستكمل اجراءات
كفالته وفقا لنظام الاسر البديله المعمول
به في مصر غير ان قضيه شنوده سلطت الضوء
على اشكاليه التبني في الدول الاسلاميه
فلولا الميراث والنسب واختلاط الانساب لم
انتزع طفل من كنف من
[موسيقى]
احتضنه التبني في فلك الممنوع اسئله كثيره
في هذا الملف المتارجح بين الحلال والحرام
من القاهره ارحب بمحامي عائله الطفل شنوده
المستشار القانوني الاستاذ نجيب جبرائيل
اهلا بك استاذ نجيب من خلال عملك على قضيه
الطفل شنوده وقضايا اخرى في اطار التبني
او الكفاله هل تعتبر ان القوانين في الدول
الاسلاميه ليست عادله في هذا الاطار وهل
برايك الحل هو في تشريع التبني قوانين
ليست عادله باعتبار ان القانون المصري لا
يبيح التبني رغم ان الشريعه المسيحيه تبيح
التبني ورغم ان لائحه 1938 الخاصه
بالاحوال الشخصيه تبيح التبني ورغم ان
هناك الماده الثالثه من الدستور المصري
تبيح للغير المسلمين من المسيحيين واليهود
ان يحتكم الى شرائعهم لكن للاسف الشديد
يعني ان هناك اصوات تقول ان يعني الولد
يولد بالفطره الاسلاميه ولكن انا اشكر
علماء الازهر الذين افادونا بان ليست
الفطره الاسلاميه هي الفطره الدينيه وانما
هي الفطره الانسانيه فالولد يولد على
الفطره الانسانيه وليست على الفطره
الدينيه ه حسب المستقر عليه في المذهب
الحنفي وبالتالي نحن يعني اخذنا هذه
الفتوى وتقد بها الى النيابه العامه
واستنادا الى هذه الفتوى والى راي مشيخه
الازهر وايضا شهاده صادره من الكنيسه
القبطيه بان الطفل وجد في مكان مسيحي في
الكنيسه
والعثرة مساله قضيه الطفل شنوده بالتحديد
بشكل عام اليوم سيدي يعني هل احتكام
القانون المصري الى الشريعه الاسلاميه هو
ما يعيق تشريع التبني بشكل عام في مصر لمن
اراد يعني ان كان مسلما ام مسيحيا ام
يهوديا ام ام يعني بدون دين بالتاكيد هم
يستندوا الى الماده الثانيه بال الدستور
التي تقول ان الشريعه الاسلاميه هي المصدر
الرئيسي للتشريع وبالتالي يعني يقولون
بعدم التبني طيب اذا كان يعني هذا الامر
يعنيي وز للمسلمين وانا احترم هذه الشريعه
الاسلاميه طبعا واحترم اخوات المسلمين لكن
يعطون حقنا نحن كمسيحيين الكتاب المقدس
ينص على التبني الماده الثالثه من الدستور
تعطينا ان نحتكم الى كتبنا المقدسه
وبالتالي يعني انا اعتقد لا غبار ولا غل
في ان نحتكم الى شراعنا طيب ربما يعني
حلقه اخرى عن هذا الموضوع بالتحديد يعني
مساله القوانين وكيف تطبق على كل الطوائف
بشكل عام دون الاخذ بعين الاعتبار يعني
الاستثناءات او الاختلافات دعني اذهب الى
عم مع الوزير السابق للاوقاف والشؤون
الاسلاميه في المملكه الهاشميه الاردنيه
الدكتور هايل داوود اهلا بك دكتور هايل
اخترنا ان نبدا بقضيه الطفل شنوده لما
فيها من تقاطع ربما بين ما هو ديني
واجتماعي وقانوني كيف تقارب هذه القضيه
انسانيا وبناء عليه الا ترى انه قد حان
وقت الاجتهاد ربما في مساله التبني لدى
المسلمين بشكل عام لا شك انه مساله التبني
او الكفاله والاحتضان هي مساله اجتماعيه
كبيره وهي هي مساله انسانيه
اي تمس قطاع عريض من الاطفال فاقدي السند
الاسري سواء كانوا مجهولين نسب او معلومين
نسب ولكن الحقيقه في ه القضيه قبل ان نمضي
بعيدا في الاحكام الفقهيه لابد يعني في
هذه المساله اختي الكريمه ان نكون على
يعني يقين بانه لكل مجتمع من المجتمعات له
خصوصيته الثقافيه وه خصوصيته القان
قانونيه ولا يجوز يعني
ان نلقي ما عليه ثقافه مجتمع في مجتمع اخر
نحن في البلاد المسلمه كمجتمعات اسلاميه
نا خصوصيتنا الثقافيه والدينيه النابعه من
احكام الاسلام ومن دين الاسلام فاذا كان
هنالك فئات اخرى من الناس سواء كانوا في
داخل العالم الاسلامي او في خارجه لهم
خصوصيات في هذه المسائل ف نحن لا ناخذ
عليهم في هذا الموضوع ولا نعتبر ان ما
ذهبوا اليه انساني او غير انساني فانا
بدايه ارجو ان لا نسقط المفاهيم ولا نعتبر
ان ما عليه فريق ما او بلد ما او مجتمع ما
هو الصوره المثلى التي لا يجوز مخالفتها
لانه هذا الحقيقه في حق مصادره ل الثقافات
الاخرى ولقيم الاخرى نحن نناقش فيها في
ثقافات المجتمعات الاسلاميه التي ربما
يعني تستم تشريعاتها من من وحي الشريعه
الاسلاميه يعني وهذا النقاش موجود حتى بين
العلماء المسلمين وتم النقاش حول الحجاب
في هذه المساله وحول مواضيع متعدده ومنها
التبني اليوم التبني لماذا ليس هناك
اجتهاد لماذا هذا الثبوت على على التحريم
بتعرفي في المسائل الاختي الكريمه في
المسائل الدينيه هنالك مسائل ثابته لا
تغيير فيها لانها مسائل قاطعه لا اجتهاد
فيها لانه جاءت فيها نصوص ثابته لا تتغير
فمثلا مساله التبني باتفاق العلماء لا لم
لا يوجد احد يناقش من علماء المسلمين لا
قديما ولا حديثا في هذه المساله ان التبني
جائز والسبب في ذلك انه في نص محكم واضح
في كتاب الله عز وجل
يقول ادعوهم لابائهم اها و وبالتالي لما
كانت ادعوهم لابائهم لا يجوز ان يكون
هنالك تبني بمعنى الحاق نسب هذا الطفل
سواء كان مجهول النسب او غير مجهول النسب
او معلوم النسب لا يحق الحاق نسبه بانسان
اخر ف مساله التبني هذه يعني كما ذكرت
حضرتك وكلامك ص لا خلاف فيها بين العلماء
ولكن المساله بعد اذنك بعد اذنك فقط
المساله التي ذكرت والحاله التي ذكرت لذلك
الطفل الذي وجد امام يعني كنيسه مسيحيه في
مصر هذه مساله نعم فيها خلاف بين العلماء
انه هذا الطفل الذي يلتقط هل ينسب لملتقي
وبالتالي ام انه يكون علىه الاسلام هناك
اراء في ه المساله وال العلماء في مصر
والازهر اختار رايا معينا في هذه المس
ولكن هذا ليس نقاش يعني نحن نحاول ان
نناقش تبني ربما اخترنا قضيه شنوده لانها
يعني تسلط الضوء على العديد من المشاكل في
ان معا طيب دعني اذهب الى الرباط بما انك
تحدثت عن ان يعني ثبوت التحريم حول التبني
لدى العلماء من الرباط ارحب بالكاتب
والباحث في نقد التراث الديني وعلم مقارنه
الاديان الاستاذ رشيد ايلال اهلا بك استاذ
رشيد وشكرا لحضورك معنا الاسلام يحرم
التبني بناء على على ما ذكره الكتور هايل
وبناء على ربما امور اخرى ايضا كيف يقارب
التيار التنويري اليوم في الاسلام هذا
التحريم يعني انت هل ترى ان ان كما كما
قال دكتور هيل ان الامر يعني ثابت لا نقاش
فيه كل شيء
[موسيقى]
يناقش وتعرفين ويعرف جميعا بان علي بن ابي
طالب يقول القران حمال اوجه وهؤلاء الذين
هؤلاء الفقهاء الذين حرموا التبني لم
يميزوا بين الاب والوالد فخلط بين
المفهومين فقد يكون الوالد غير اب يعني
ولد وتخلى ولم يربي ولم يحمي هذا الطفل
ولم يرعاه فهو ليس س ابا له وقد يكون
والدا وابا وقد يكون ابا وهو غير والد
وهذا واضح في الايه ال من سوره النساء
التي تحدثت عن عن المحرمات عن المحارم
حرمت عليكم امهاتكم الى ان
قال وابناؤكم الذين من اصلابكم يعني يمكن
ان يكون لديك ابن غير من
غير صلب الشخ
يعني ليس ولده ولكنه ابن الله وهذا مفهوم
عند الفقهاء بالدليل بمفهوم المخالفه نعم
فعندما جاؤوا بالايه القرانيه التي تقول
ادعوهم لابائهم فهذه الايه تتحدت ان الشخص
الشخص يجب ان يحمل اسم الشخص الذي رباه
ورعاه وحما وليس الوالد الذي لم يكن ابا
نعم يعني انت تميز بين الاب والوالد ودعنا
فقط لغويا يعني وفق المعجم يعني الوالد هو
من يلد يعني بالحديث عن النطفه او النسب
المباشر البيولوجي والاب هو يعني يعني
صاحب اللقاح نعم صاحب اللقاح والاب هو
الذي يرعى يعني يربي يعني يمكن ان يكون
ليس ولد اب يرعى ويربي ويحمي طيب طيب
دكتور ها لديك ما تقول قبل ان اذهب الى
تونس ونتعرف على ضيفنا الرابع
والاخير طبعا اختي الكريمه يعني ما ذهب
اليه الضيف والزميل الكريم انا بعتقد انه
يعني لم يكن صائبا فيما فسره لان الايه
القرانيه التي تلوت في هذا الموضوع ايه
واضحه لماذا نفهم نذهب الى مفهوم المخالفه
في اللغه العربيه مفهوم المخالفه موجود
ولكن هذا المفهوم ضعيف عندما يكون هنالك
لفظ صريح اللفظ الصريح يقول وما جعل
ادعيائكم ابنائكم ويقول ادعوهم لابائهم
هذا هنا لفظ وهو نص يسمى في اللغه العربيه
هذا نص مقابل مفهوم المخالفه لا يعتد
بمفهوم المخالفه سيد رشيد ها قواعد اصول
الفقه التي يستنبط منها الفقهاء الاحكام
عرفتي اختي الكريمه مقابل النص الواضح لا
ينظر الى مفهوم المخالفه واكيد انه ضيفك
الكريم يعلم هذا هو تحدث عن الايه
القرانيه وتحدث عن الاب وهو هو يعرف جيدا
ان اللغه العربيه ليس فيها ترادف فكل كلمه
تؤدي معنى محدد فالوالد ليس هو الاب وحتى
ابراهيم ابراهيم ابوه يعرف انه هو طارح
ولكنه ورد ان لديه ازر الذي رباه لذلك جاء
في
القران وقال
ابراهيم لابيه
ازر ف ميز بين الوالد هنا و والاب ثانيا
تحدث عن التحريم انا اتحدى ايا كان الذي
يحرم التبني ان ياتي بايه توضح ان التبني
حرام هكذا بالتحريم لكن هؤلاء ياخذون نصوص
متشابهه تفيد معاني متعدده ولكنهم يقولون
الله ما لم تقل وهو يعلم ان الله يقول في
القران انه من المحرمات ان تقولوا على
الله ما لا تعلمون ف الله ليس جاهل
بالعربيه عندما قال
اباؤكم ابناؤكم الذين من اصلابكم ففيه
دلاله قويه على ان هناك ابناء ليسوا من
الصلب نراه ك نقاش دكتور هايل يعني هل هل
هل نناقش ربما ولا بالنسبه اليك لا نناقش
يجب ان يكون النقاش بالاسلوب العلمي
فعندما يقول ضيفك الكريم هؤلاء يقولون
القران الكريم ما لا يقول هذا كلام اخي
مردود عليك ل فارجو ان نتزم اسلوب الحوار
العلمي انت الذي
تقول ليس انا اتحدث بصفه عامه وعندما تقول
ان النقاش ليس علميا فلست وحدك سيدي التي
تملك المنهجيه العلميه اطفال المكاتب
يعرفون انه لا
ترادف الما تقولون القران هذه غير صحيحه
المكان القران سبب النزول لكي لا
نذهب الريم نري سنزول الذ تسمحي يا اخت ر
لان المشكله في الحقيقه ان النص يحتمل
مع سبب نزول الايه
القرانيه تفضل سبب نزول الايه القرانيه
يوضح المقصود فيها والكل يعلم ان سبب نزول
الايه القرانيه هي في قصه تبني النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم لزيد بن حارثه فكان يسمى
زيد بن محمد فجاءت الايه القرانيه تقول له
ان هذا ليس ابنك وان هذا اسمه زيد بن
حارثه فبعد ان كان يسميه الناس والعرب
والمسلمون زيد بن محمد عاد اسمه الى زيد
بن حارثه ص فسبب النزول عند المفسرين هو
ايضا يوضح المعنى المراد بالايه سيد رشيد
هذه يعني وهذه معروفه يعني انه هذه القصه
هو هو يعلم هو هو يعلم ان نعم هو هو يعلم
ان عبره بعموم اللفظ لا بخصوص السبب هذا
اولا مساله ثانيه قصص وروايات اسباب
النزول هي وضعت بعد ازيد من 200 سنه على
وفاه الرسول فهي ق قصص لا يعتد بها
تاريخيا تتحدث عن الاحاديث هي مجرد روايات
اخباريه نعم كل الاحاديث بما فيها اسبال
ال نزود هي احاديث
ف هي هي اسبا عندما ورد اليوم في منهاج
يعني التفسير ل لدى علماء ال مع كامل
الاسف لانهم جعلوا من القران نص تيا
ويريدون ان يعيدوا كل كل الامور الفقهيه
الى الماضي ولا يستطيعون ان يتعاملوا مع
النص بغض النظر عن السياق التاريخي الى
سياق هم التاريخي في حاضرهم ومستقبلهم طيب
ل يعمدوا الى استنباط افكار تناسب عصرهم
هم يريدون ان يعيشوا في جلباب الاباء رغم
ان
عقليه اتباع الاباب هي عقليه مرفوضه
ومنبوذ في القران دكتور هيل فقط لو سمحت
اعطيك حق الرد قبل ان قبل ان نستكمل في
موضوعنا
تفضل نعم طبعا اختي الكريمه هذا المنهج
وهذه المدرسه المعروفه التي ترفض الحديث
الشريف ولا تقبل الاخذ بالحديث الشريف هذه
مدرسه بالنسبه الينا مدرسه مرفوضه وغير
مقبوله لاننا نعتبر ان السنه النبويه
الكريمه والحديث الشريف هو مصدر ثاني بعد
القران الكريم في اخذ الاحكام الشرعيه وهي
المفسره وال المبينه والموضح لكثير مما
جاء في القران الكريم نقطه وبس يعني طيب
خلاص اوك
يعني ضيفك الكريم ان
يعطين اتحدى ضيفك الكريم ان يعطيني 30 ايه
30 ايه فقط فسرتها الاحاديث اتحد ط لكي لا
ندخل في موضوع اخرم القران والكل يعلم هذا
سنبقى في التبني الان وربما يعني نقيم
حلقه مناظره اخرى بينكما تتناقش في هذه
المساله دعونا نذهب الى تونس مع المتخصص
في علم النفس السيد عبد الباسط الفقيه
اهلا بك السيد عبد الباسط تونس هي الدوله
العربيه الوحيده ذات الغالبيه المسلمه
التي شرعت التبني من زاويه علم النفس ما
هي المشاكل التي يمكن للتبني ان يحلها على
المستوى الاجتماعي والفردي مساله التخلي
الاولى سواء كان تخلي الوالدين او ال يعني
في في ظروف اجتماعيه صعبه والا في حاله
يتم مثلا والا في حاله علاقه يعني يعني
بدون زواج يعني خارج اطار الزواج فان وجود
وجود الاطفال في غير الاطار العائلي هذايا
باش يدفعهم انهم يعيشوا في وضعيه معناتها
اقل ما يقال فيها ان مصدر
للاتعاظ والوجود الصحي والوجود الذي يمكن
ان يخفف من هذه الالام هو وجود داخل اسره
المشرع التونسي منذ سنه
1958 يعني سهل او يسر هذا الامر على الذين
يريدون تبني هؤلاء الاطفال ولكن انا اتصور
ان التشريعات المختلفه والمتتالية
شعات من اجل اجبار الوالد البيولوجي على
الاعتراف حتى يلحق النسب او باللقب و نعم
طيب يعني وهذا على المستوى الطفل على
المستوى بشكل عام بالنسبه اليك التبني يحل
مساله النسب ليس كما اليوم يعني كما كما
من الحجج التي تعطى ان التبني يفرض او
يمكن ان يؤدي الى مشاكل في تخالط الانساب
انت بالنسبه لك اجتماعيا يمكن ان يحل تبني
مساله الانساب لا اعتقد ان تخالط الانساب
هذه مساله فقهيه يخذ فيها اهل الاختصاص
انا اتحدث عن مساله واحده فقط وهو انتماء
هؤلاء الاطفال الى اسر ن بعد ان كانوا في
اسر في يعني مراكز ايواء او دور ايتام الن
بالكيد الحضانه او الرعايه التي ناتي منها
النسب مهم النسب مهم النسب مهم لانه مرتبط
بهويه الفرد النسب مهم جدا لكن بالنسبه
للاطفال الذين تم تبنيهم فانه الحاقهم
بهذا هذا الانتماء وهذا اللقب بالتاكيد له
تبعات ايجابيه جدا ولكن لابد ان نكون
حذرين لانه عند عند يعني اكتشاف السر بين
ظفرين لهذا الامر ربما يصبح ذلك مصدر شقاء
بالنسبه للوالدين ولذلك لابد من الحذر في
هذا الامر لانه الاصل في انا انا اتصور
انه انسب الاشياء انه مكاشفه هؤلاء
الاطفال على الاقل عندما يقع تبنيهم وهم
كبار المفروض انهم يعرفون تماما اصلهم
البيولوجي والعائله التي تبناهم طيب نعرف
معنا في المجتمع الغربي على الاقل قد
تجاوز هذا الامر كثيرا نعم خاصه في زمن
يعني الحمض النووي واختبارات الدي ان اي
طيب عدم الانجاب نوي بالشركات الخاصه ن
استاذ نجيب جبرائيل مصطلح الاحتضان مستخدم
في مصر ايضا هل شرحته لنا لو سمحت وما
الذي يفرقه عن التبني الذي نعرفه ان في
تونس او في دول الغرب لا هو نبدا بالتبني
التبني هو تبني طفل واعطاه اسم اسم الاب
واسم الام ايضا وايضا ان يرث هذا الطفل
وكل مال الطفل الشرعي هو مال الطفل
المتبنى هذا هو مفهوم التبني او متفق عليه
وطبعا ده مش موجود في مصر اما الحضانه فهو
الحضانه يعني زي بالضبط شبيه
ب الاحتضان شبيه بالاسر البديله او
بالكفاله انت بتتبني او تحتضن طفل بتقدمي
ليه كل شيء بتراعيه بشروط معينه وبتشرف
عليه لجنه
من الداره التضامن الاجتماعي لكن لا ياخذ
اسم الذ النسب لا ياخذ النسب لا ياخذ لا
ياخذ النسب ولا يرث وانما يجوز له ان تكون
هناك هبه او وصيه لكن لا يرس طيب ده ده
باختصار شديد لكن دعيني اعلق بصراحه وانا
الحقيقه بشكر طبعا ضيوفنا كلنا لكن انا
اركز على الاستاذ عبد الباسط من تونس
الحقيقه لاني شرحها دي قضيه انسانيه وانا
اعتقد كمان ان الديانات باجمعها هي مصدر
القيم الانسانيه نعم فيعني الحفاظ على هذه
المساله طبعا يعني انا ك في مصر ايضا انا
لا اطالب يعني غير مسلمين غير المسيحيين
بالتبني وانما اطالب بالمسيحيين بالتبني
كحق مشروع موجود في الديانه المسيحيه
وايضا موجود في الدستور المصري فيما يتعلق
بحق المسيحيين طبقا للماده الثانيه وصلت
فكرتك شكرا استاذ نجيب دكتور هايل يعني
اليوم يحتضن الطفل يعامل على انه جزء من
الاسره ولكن لا نعطيه النسب ولا يرث الا
ترى ان هناك ربما ظلما كبيرا بحق هؤلاء
الاطفال في هذه المساله اليس من دور الدين
احيانا ان يكون يسرا بمعنى ان ييسر حياه
المؤمنات والمؤمنين خاصه ان هؤلاء الاطفال
غالبا نتحدث عن اطفال مسلمين وبالتالي
يعني يعني هناك ظلم كيف يمكن ان ترد على
هذا الريم تفضلي تفضل اعتقد بالمقابل اختي
الكريمه وبالصراحه انا اعتقد ان من الظلم
ان ننسب هذا الاب ابن الى غير ابيه الشرعي
من الظلم هذا هو الظلم وليس الظلم في ان
يدين والشريعه الاسلاميه وكل حتى لو هو هم
هؤلاء الاطفال الذين يحتاجون الى التبني
او الى الحضانه هم على نوعين اختي الكريمه
في هناك مجهولين نسب وفي هناك معلومين نسب
تمام اذا كان معلوم النسب هذا كيف ينسب
الى غير ابيه هذا مصادره لحق الطفل لان
لان من رباه ليس ابيه يحفظ حقه في ان ينسب
الى ابيه الان اذا اعطينا نسب هذا الطفل
معلوم النسب الى غير ابيه بالعكس هذا هو
الظلم اثنين بالنسبه لموضوع الميراث
الميراث في ظلم لاصحاب الحق في الميراث
صحيح اننا نريد ان ننصف هذا الطفل ولكن
ايضا ليس على حساب الاخرين وبالتالي في
عندنا حل لهي القضيه اختي الكريمه وهي
مساله الوصيه التي قد تعطيه احيانا اكثر
من حقه في الميراث فيجوز لمن احتضن هذا
الطفل ان يوصي اليه بوصي
تصل الى ثلث التركه
وبالتالي لا نحرمه من حقه في مال هذا الذي
احتضنه اما اذا كان مجهول النسب فكذلك هذا
مجهول النسب يعني لا يجوز ان نهمه او ان
نجعله يعيش في الاوهام ان هذا هو والده
الحقيقي وبالتالي انا بعتقد انه بالعكس ما
ذهبت اليه الشريعه الاسلاميه في موضوع حق
الرعايه والحت
والكفاله هو اكثر انسانيه واكثر عدلا في
حق هذا الطفل الصغير من ان ياخذ النسب او
ان يرث بشكل عادي كغيره من الناس في طيب
اوكي وصلت فكرتك دكتور هايل استاذ رشيد
يعني كما في مساله الميراث التي يحدها
الدين بشروط هناك ايضا التبني هناك ايضا
الاجهاض الامن وغيرها من الامور يعني التي
تشكل اليوم وما زالت تشكل في الكث كثير من
المجتمعات ذات الغالبيه المسلمه تبو او
يعني مختلف عليها او محرمه برايك عدم
تغيير القوانين المتعلقه بهذه الشؤون يؤثر
على استقرار هذه المجتمعات بشكل عام هل
يخلق ربما جوا من النفاق الاجتماعي هناك
ناس تزور احيانا او تتحايل على القانون
لكي
تتبنى يعني ونعلم ان هذا ما يحصل بشكل عام
بكل تاكيد القوانين اصلا توضع من اجل ان
نحقق العداله من اجل ان نحق حق الاستقرار
لذلك في القوانين دائمه التغيير ف نجرب
القوانين نضع القوانين عندما تظهر لنا
عيوبها نحاول ان نضع قوان جديده والهدف
الاساس هو تحقيق العدل
و حتى يكون لدينا مجتمع متصالح مع نفسه
لكن هذا التشبت بالماضي بشكل رهيب وباج
تهادت محكومه بزمانها ومكانها وعدم عيش
عصرنا بدعوه الدين فهذا امر يؤدي فعلا الى
جعل مجتمع خارج هذا الدين خارج هذه المتور
هيل كان يقول هناك حلول يعني هناك
الاحتضان انه اوكي تحتضن العائله الطفل
بدون ان تعطيه النسب ولا الميراث نعم
نعم الدكتور يرى المساله من فوق ولا يراها
من تحت يعني يراعي
مصلحه ذلك الشخص ولا ينظر الى الطفل هو
المعني الاساس عندما يخرج طفل الى الشارع
ويرى انه يعيش داخل اسره لا يحمل اسمها
كيف سيحس ما هي العقد النفسيه التي سيصاب
بها الن يحس يحس بالدونيه
الن ماذا سيجيب الاطفال الاخرين عندما
يقول له هذا انا اعيش مع هذ الاسره ولا
احمل اسمها هل انا ابن غير شرعي هل انا
كذا هل انا كذا ونقع في دوامه من الامور
التي تعطي نتائج عكسيه تؤثر على هذا الطفل
سلبا لكن اذا اعطينا لهذا الطفل ما دنب
هذا الطفل اصلا الذي فقد اباه او رمي في
الشارع ام يعني الحق في التبني اصلا نشا
من مبدا من ميثاق حقوق الطفل يعني هو هو
ليس حق العائله في ان يكون لديها طفلا بل
حق كل طفل في ان تكون له عائله اريد ان
اسال في هذا الاطار على المستوى النفسي
السيد عبد الباسط الفقيه اليوم نفسيا
الطفل او الطفله الذي يحتضن او تتم ك فته
من قبل اسره مع التحفظ على حقه في الميراث
او النسب نسب هذه العائله هل يتاثر بشكل
سلبي بالمقارنه مع طفل متبنى بشكل
كامل هو الطفل هذا الذي تم تبنيه يتاثر
بشكل سلبي حتى ان كان شكله مثلا مخالف
لشكل بقيه الاسره نعرف جيدا مثلا في
البلدان الاوروبيه عندما يتم تبني اطفال
من اسيا وابوين من اوروبا الغربيه فانه
وجود هذا الاختلاف فقط هو مصدر قلق
بالنسبه للطفل ومصدر سؤال وحيره ربما
تثيرها يثيرها تعليق الاتراب او الوصم
الذي يتلقاه هذا الطفل من ولكن انا اتصور
انه ما دامت الاسره ضامنه لهذا الحد
الادنى من الامان العاطفي والاطمئنان
والانتساب لانه هو الطفل ماذا يحتاج الطفل
في الاصل هو لا تهم هذه الشكليات
القانونيه وانما يهمه الانتماء النفسي
والعاطفي عندما يحس هذا الطفل الى انتماء
الى اسرى لم يعد يعني مجرد فرد
في يعني ماوى ايتام او مجرد ربما في جمعيه
يتداول عليها مربون كثر فانه عندما ينتمي
الى هذه الاسره حتى ان لم يحمل هذا الاسم
او هذا اللقب فانه ديما ظرف امان افضل
بكثير هذا لا يمنع من حدوث الحيره في سن
في سن المراهقه بصفه عامه لانه هو حتى
الطفل العادي في اطار حيرته المستمره
وحيرته الوجوديه ان صح التعبير يطرح اسئله
كثيره يعني تقريبا محورها الاساسي هو الشك
في هذا الانتماء او صدق الانتماء مع هذه
الاسره لكن في كل الاحوال الاطفال الذين
ينحدرون من اوساط سواء كانوا ايتام او وقع
التخلي عنهم او وجدوا في وضعيه بدون عائله
ان صح التعبير عندما يوجدون في وضع عائلي
فان ذلك اولا اضافه الى اعتباره من اولى
حقوقهم فانه مصدر امان كثير ومصدر امان
حتى لمجتمع حتى يتحول هذا الطفل الى و
تماما تمام دكتور هايل يعني اريد ان اسالك
في مساله الحقوق اليوم يعني اليوم الدول
الاسلاميه بغالب صادقت على على ميثاق مبدا
حقوق الطفل الذي يعني يقول في في في
الماده الثالثه والرابعه بحق الاطفال بان
تكون لهم كل طفل في ان تكون له عائله وان
يكون لديه كل الحقوق التي تؤمنها هذه
العائله اليوم كيف في الدول الحديث حديث
التي نعيش فيها يعني دول الاسلاميه هي دول
حديثه التي نعيش فيها كيف يمكن ان نوفق
بين هذه الشق بين هذا الشق الحقوقي الذي
نصادق عليه وبين المساله الدينيه التي
تاتي
بشروط يعني ربما تحرم هؤلاء الاطفال من
حقوقهم الاخرى اختي الكريمه هذا ال
اتفاقيه اتفاقيه حقوق الطفل هي تتحدث عن
الاطفال بشكل عام وان هذا حق للطفل الان
هذا الطفل فقد السند هي حاله استثنائيه
ويجب ان نتعامل ونعالجها بطريقه استثنائيه
الطريقه الاستثنائيه انه حق الطفل ان تكون
له عائله في الاحتضان اختي الكريمه تكون
له عائله في الاحتضان تكون له اسره في
الاحتضان نؤمن له الرعايه الاجتماعيه
والرعايه الماليه والرعايه التربويه وكل
الامور باستثناء انه لا ينسب الى هذه
العائله وليس له حق الميراث كما قلت قبل
قليل حق الميراث نحن بنحله في موضوع
الوصيه اما في موضوع النسب فهذه المساله
يعني لانها حاله استثنائيه طيب يعني ال
اتفاقيه الطفل تتحدث عن الاطفال بشكل عام
وبالتالي هي تتحدث عن 99 و99 و9 بالمئه من
الاطفال الان هذه الحاله الاستثنائيه كما
قلت نعالجها بطريقه استثنائيه لا تتعارض
مع القواعد الدينيه طيب اي سيد رشيد يعني
بما تعلق بين المساله الحقوقيه المساله
الدينيه اليوم يعني هناك هذا هذا هذه
الهوه الموجوده ليس فقط في ملف التبني
ولكن ما نتحدث عن التبني كيف تعلق على هذا
الامر الاصل في الدين ان يحقق الحقوق
للناس ان يسعد البشريه لعكس يعني عندما
ياتي الدين فيجب ان يساير حاجات الناس
ويجب ان يلبي حقوق الناس وان يحققها اما
اذا كان لدي دين مخالف لهذه الامور فهذا
طبعا ليس من الدين في شيء وقد قيل قديما
حيث ما كان العدل كان الدين نعم ف عندما
تحقق العداله وتحقق الحقوق وتحقق السعاده
للبشريه وللانسان فانك فعلا داخل الدين
اما اذا بدات في نظرك انت تطبق الدين ولا
تتحقق العداله وتتسبب في كو اليوم الكفاله
وضان كنت باسم الدين لا تحقق العداله
الكفاله والاحتضان يعني هناك حلول اوجدها
الدين ل للاطفال طبعا طبعا في الحقيقه
اوجدها الفقيه ولم يوجدها الدين لان حتى
الكفاله لا توجد هذا هذا المفهوم في
القران يوجد الاباء في القران الذين
يتبنون والايه واضحه تقول عندما تحدث عن
المحارم كان الايه 23 من سوره النساء
وابناؤكم الذين من اصلابكم يعني هناك
ابناء ليسوا من اصلابكم طيب فالامر واضح
ولكن الفقيه لديه مشكل يقول لك اختلاط
الانساب يقول لك كذا نحن في القرن ال1
الكل يتفق عن انه عن طريق لادين يمكن ان
تعرف النسب فال المساله محسومه علميا
مساله اخرى هناك قاعده اصوليه لدى الفقهاء
انه من اصول التشريع شرع من قبلنا ونعرف
ان في في التشريعات الدينيه السابقه
كالمسيح مثلا يجوز التبني لماذا لا يفعل
الفقهاء هذا الاصل من اصول التشريع هو شرع
من قبلنا شرع لنا فشرع اليهود وشرع
المسيحيين هو شرع للمسلمين ايضا لماذا لا
يفعلونه في قضيه التبني ولكن هناك تشبث
بالماضي و و غريب
ج
حقف هنا ساعطيك الكلمه ساعطيك الكلمه
دكتور تفضل دكتور يل يعني يبدو ان الضيف
يخلط امور كثيره ببعضها اولا انا برجع
بكرر مره ثانيه الايه التي يستدل بها في
موضوع اخر مختلف بينما الايه التي استدلت
بها نص في هذا
الموضوع
لمارس
الاستذ انت الذي لا تعرف العيب انت الذي
لا تعرف العيب لا تتحدث بهه الصيه تقول لا
تتح بدون اهانات شخصيه
د ال بدون اان شخصيه لانه
لاسمع بعد لو سمحت ما لو سمحت ما دكتور هي
انا اعطيتك الكلمه استاذ رشيد لو سمح اقول
انت تستدل
بايات لو فلا تجعلي يقاطعني لو سمحت تفضل
تفضل انا اقول ان المتحدث الكريم ياتي بن
نص ليس في موضوع الحديث وانا استدل باياته
نص في موضوع الحديث هذا واحد اثنين قبل
قليل يقول اتيني ب 30 حديث فيه تفسير
لايات القران الكريم بقول انه يرجع الى
صحيح البخاري وصحيح مسلم والسنن الاربعه
يجد في كل منها كتاب فيه عشرات الاحاديث
التي هي تفسيرات للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
في القران الكريم ثالثا يقول شرع من قبلنا
نعم شرع من قبلنا شرع لنا ولكن فيما لا
يتعارض مع شرعنا فاذا كان شرع من قبلنا
يتعارض مع ما عندنا انا احترم الاخوه
المسيحيين يقولون في ديانتنا هنالك تبني
اوكي يمكن ان يطبق هذا الامر عليهم وانا
لا امانع في ذلك ولكن في ديانتنا التبني
محرم وليس جائز وبالتالي شرعهم في هذه
القضيه ليس شرعنا هذه هي اصول الفقه التي
يتعلمها المختصون في هذا المجال طيب
الاشاره فقط يعني استاذ رشيد
ايلال لحظه لحظه انت انت بس عندك يعني
نشرت كتاب عنوانه نهايه اسطوره البخاري
انت يعني تنتقد بشده مساله الرجوع الى
الاحاديث يعني وهذا نقاش يمكن ان يحصل
دكتور هايل بينكما يعني في ضمن اطار طبعا
قواعد قواعد احترام الحوار تفضل استاذ
رشيد باختصار نعم انا عندما تحديت قلت له
اعطيني 30 ايه شرح احاديث ولم اقل اعطني
30 حديث يشرح ايه مثلا فالتحدي الذي طرحته
لم يجيب عليه اصلا وقني اشياء هذه
الاحاديث اخي الاث
ايت اتيت
بايات هو يرفض الا يقاطع ويقاطع تفضل تفضل
لا لم يقاطع اراد فقط ان يقول لك انه تفضل
اجابك على الفكره تفضل استاذ على العموم
هو هو يعرف انه في صبيح البخاري
تبويب تبويب بايه مثلا وتجد في ذلك الباب
لا يوجد ولا حديث واحد ويعرف انه في صحيح
البخاري تبويب بايه وياتي باحاديث ضد
الايه يعني شوقت الايه الى الى الى حلقه
عن الاحاديث سنقوم بها لاحقا دعوني فقط
قبل ان اختم اريد ان اذهب الى
مصر على العموم هو التوضيح اخت الكريمه
كتاب
الت ا تفضل استاذ دقيقه دقيقه تفضل فالله
اذا اراد ان يحرم شيئا يقول فضلك ايه حرمت
عليكم كذا حرمت عليكم كذا نعم ف طيب سي
وهو يقول لك انه في شرعنا اشياء
محرمه في في شرع من قبلنا اشياء محرمه
ليست لدينا طيب طيب نش الوصايا العشر
الموجوده اخر وسيكون مشكن اخت الكريمه
تسمحي اختي الكريمه تفضل دكتور هي لا
باختصار بدي خ نصف
دقف المج في القر نصف دقيقه اختي الكريمه
حتى اوضح حتى اوضح حلائل ابنائكم الذين من
اصلابكم ليست دائما هنا بمعنى مفهوم
المخالفه هنا معناها ايها الرجل كيف تجرؤ
وكيف يروق لك وكيف يمكن ان تتزوج زوجه
ابنك الذي هو من صلبك عرفتم المعنى هنا ما
المقصود فيه وليس من مفهوم المخالفه ح
ابنائكم الذين من اصلابكم فاذا لم يكونوا
من اصلابكم لا معناها كما قالت الايه التي
قبلها وربائبكم التي في حجوركم يعني اذا
لم تكن في
حجره لا تق
يقولون
الشول في
الشخ
يا اساتذه لو سمحت انا اريد ان لان الوقت
انتهى سنقوم
بدعوتك الى مناظره الها علاقه بالاحد لا
بالقران ولا بسنه طيب خلينا لا داعي
لتكفير الناس يا استاذ دكتور هيل لو سمحت
لا داعي لتكفير الناس بتاتا نحن هنا في
هذا البرنامج لا نقل هذا ل لا لا تؤمن
بالقران دع دعنا لكي نذهب ساذهب الى مصر
لكي يعني نخفف التوتر فان ك
لو سمحت لكي لا نذهب بالنقاش الى مكان اخر
ساذهب الى سي انت تحرف ايات القران الكريم
لو سمح دكتور هايل خلص حلقه ثانيه بنحكي
بالموضوع سيد نجيب سيد نجيب لو سمحت اليوم
كلمه اخيره في اطار مساله اختي مشي لو
سمحتي لو سمحت انا هقول لحضرتك هقول
لحضرتك المسائل الدينيه مسائل حساسه
للغايه وسوف يظل هذا الجدل مستمرا وسوف
يكون الا اطفال ضحايا هذا الجدن
الا طالما الدساتير العربيه مرتبطه
بالاديان انا من رايي ان الدول الدوله
المدنيه هي الحسم والفصل في هذا الموضوع
طيب اضافه اخيره من تونس تفضل استاذ هذه
القوانين وهذه التشريعات التي يصنعها
المجتمع في نهايه الامر انما وجدت لحل
مشكلات لدينا
مشكله متكرره ودائمه وظاهره ثابته في
المجتمع نحن في تونس مثلا عندنا اكثر من
1000 طفل سنويا يولدون خارج اطار الزواج
نعم هؤلاء يحتاجون الى حظن عائلي لانه ليس
ليس لديهم
يعني اي فرصه اخرى حتى حت حتى ينش اسوياء
الحل في قدره المجتمع على احتضان هؤلاء و
يعني ضمهم الى العائلات لان الطفل الذي
ينشا ضمن عائله هذا طفل مؤمن ضد
الانحرافات وضد عد
انا اتمنى مستقر نفسيا ويكون على الاقل
عنصر امان للمجتمع ش كما ينشا في بيئه
امنه فانه سيحول ذلك الى امان شكرا لك
دكتور هي الكلمه اخيره لو سمحت في هذا
الاطار التبني او الكفاله او الحضانه هي
اساليب لتحقيق الدعم النفسي والرعايه
الاجتماعيه والماليه والتربويه لهذا
الاطفال لا فرق كبير بينهما هما يعني
متقاربان جدا باستثناء مسائل بسيطه في ظن
ان
الكفاله والحضانه هي اكثر انسانيه بهذا
الطفل من موضوع التمني اشكرك
دكتور وحق الطفل من موضوع التبن شكرا على
سعه صدرك وشكرا ايضا على سعه صدرك يا
استاذ رشيد تفضل كلمه اخيره لك انا اؤمن
ايمانا عميقا بان القران يقول وجعلناكم
شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا والتعارف تثقف
والتبني ثبت في كثير من دول نجاعته ونجاحه
فلا باس ان نستفيد من هذه التجارب من باب
الاستفاده من الانسان من حيث هو انسان وان
نناقش فيها والنقاش في فلك الممنوع لا
نهايه له شكرا لكل الضيوف كل شيء يناقش في
ختام هذه الحلقه اود ان اوجه تحيه الى
زميلنا ثمين الخطان ثمين يغادر فريق
البرنامج ويغادر قاعه تحرير فرانس ك في
باريس نحو مغامرات جديده باسمي وباسم سلمى
بنجاره منتج في فلك الممنوع نتمنى لك يا
ثمين كل التوفيق سنشتاق الى نقاشاتنا
البيزنطيه احيانا وسنفتح تقاريرك
ومساهماتك حتما رح نشتقلك كثير ثمينه الى
اللقاء في حلقات جديده على فرونس ان ك
ومونت كارلو الدوليه
[موسيقى]
تحياتي y